Nik Falls playing quarterback oh and
down he went you see the body weight of
Chris Jones land on Nick Foles probably
should have been roughing the passer not
that it matters Nick Falls with the
broken collarbone surgery today out
indefinitely
classy got up no hard feelings regarding
Chris Jones they were teammates in
Kansas City so look he's not doing this
on purpose he's just playing the game
and sometimes does and you always praise
Nick Foles for standing tough and
they've in the pocket but that's the
problem you hang in there too long yeah
and you and you expose yourself to that
hit you take that hit and boom he's out
who knows how long
well it just shows you it doesn't matter
how big you are when you're playing
quarterback in football yeah I mean Nick
Foles the last two years has been as
good as anybody I've seen as far as
people around them people hitting them
but remember he had the little chest
injury last year right when he got hit
there we're seeing it just doesn't
matter how big you are at the
quarterback position Andrew Luck Cam
Newton Ben Roethlisberger that's great
but you got to find ways to avoid hits
this is a game changer in the AFC I mean
hey men shipment men Schumann Chava
Gardner Minshew Minshew he did some fine
things yesterday and certainly gave us a
little hope but I don't think he's Nick
Foles and now I look at the Jaguars and
go whoa is there a lot of pressure on
this defense which lost a temper a
little bit yesterday to which I didn't
like to see and I do I questioned the
Jaguars going forward with that Nick
Foles oh the Jaguars I mean it was
chippy for awhile you know after miles
jack was ejected they still were chippy
it's like guys once they start sending
people to the showers that's when it's
time to comply with the directives of
the officials but they finally did get
it under control
another big injury in that Chiefs
Jaguars game huge win by Kansas City
Tyree chill out for a few weeks he has a
collarbone injury they took him to a
hospital and boom it was a it was kind
of ominous for a while no surgery for
Tyreke kill but he will be out for a few
weeks Sammy Watkins ended up finally
delivering on the potential that made
him the fourth overall pick in the draft
five years ago nine catches for 198
yards and three touchdowns I know he's
had other good games yeah nothing like
what we saw yesterday know exactly I
don't even care you're right he's had
other good game
it's how he looked yesterday right Mike
I mean we saw him get the ball we went
whoa that's the guy we remember in
Clemson that was picked number four in
the NFL Draft ahead of you know Brandon
cooks and Odell Beckham jr. and you said
this is this is why we made a big deal
about him I think this is the reason you
I a lot of other people in the round
sports media are excited about the
Kansas City Chiefs and I go the the
offense should be better this year
because mahomes isn't your two and if
Watkins is healthy like that and when
they get Tyreke Hill back which is gonna
hurt of course they're just got weapons
galore and they're gonna be as dangerous
as ever
you mentioned Oh BJ is he hooking you up
with one of those $350,000 watches that
he was wearing during the guy I saw that
like what is that the new thing because
you know Nadal wears that same watch why
he plays tennis so are they like giving
them this for free I don't understand
that why does anybody wear jewelry I
mean guys wear diamonds and necklace and
everything I don't get why do you need
to know what time it is during a
football why do you need any of it what
do you need you eat up but you're right
I don't understand that either and and
I've asked the NFL for comment on that
because it is intriguing the NFL has a
watch sponsor the watch yeah they're
probably not thrilled right with the
idea of the three hundred fifty thousand
dollar watch not made by the watch
sponsor being on the wrist of Odell
Beckham jr.
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports